emergencia en corea del norte por el
hobbit 19 tras más de dos años de
pandemia el país asiático por primera
vez reconoce un contagio según la
agencia central de noticias el 12 de
mayo corea del norte informó de un caso
de infección de omicron el gobierno de
kim jong-un ordenó un cierre en todas
las ciudades del país además de reforzar
los controles fronterizos los encargados
de comercios y fábricas buscarán hacer
que se respeten estancia miento social
hace dos semanas hubo dos grandes
eventos organizados por el gobierno a
los que asistieron miles de personas lo
que ha hecho que las autoridades teman
de una gran propagación el país ha
impuesto desde 2020 un rígido bloqueo
para evitar la llegada del virus y ha
frenado el comercio casi por completo
por lo que enfrenta una crítica
situación económica sus aliados chinos
anunciaron ayudas
fumando y el funk tan bien nos
solidarizamos con la situación actual de
corea del norte como camarada vecino y
amigo
china está dispuesta a prestar todo su
apoyo y ayuda a corea del norte en su
lucha contra la pandemia
según la organización mundial de la
salud a finales de 2020 corea del norte
realizó
3.259 pruebas de 19 todas con resultados
negativos los expertos aseguran que el
sistema sanitario del país no podría
enfrentar un gran brote de la pandemia